hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast controlling terpenes and
cannabinoids in flour and extract
presented by Marcus Rogan PhD
vice-president of extraction at out Co I
am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Rogan I will now turn the presentation
over to him so I welcome everyone to
this talk thank you for joining in on my
quick or hopefully enlightening
presentation of the research we have
been doing at Elko about how we control
terpenes and cannabinoids in our flour
and extract so to give you background on
extraction we just were thinking what
actually is an extract and what should
an acts trying to do so as I mentioned
this the controlling cannabinoids and
turkeys in flower and extracts that
means I want to be able to
give to the customer or the patient the
right cannabinoids they need but also
when I extract I want to represent the
flower so often we see products that
claim to be an OG Kush or or gg but they
might not be what you would expect so
with that we have to consider a few
things but let me give you an idea of
what this talk will be about we will
talk about the backgrounds we will talk
about how we optimize our extraction and
we will compare and contrast a little
and I try to bring in a few other
anecdotes and information sniffles we
found in our studies so what is an
extract so an extract is when a solvent
removes something from a matrix so
butane extraction co2 extraction
ethanol extraction would be an extra
when people talk about a rosin extract
or an ice-water hasha extract that is
actually incorrect because from a
chemical side for extraction you need a
solvent rosin is just a mechanical
separation through pressure and
temperature and water ice water extract
is actually about the same the water and
ice cubes agitate the material and you
collect the Triclops so again it's a
separation but I just wanted to bring
out these few inconsistencies or
incorrectness in distributing in
pointing terms in the cannabis industry
and I just like to point out small
mistakes but what is an extract and for
that what actually is in the cannabis
plant in the first place so we all know
about THC and CBD we have heard about
them often enough and
some people prefer the THC for the buzz
others now claim that CBD has all the
health benefits but there's more than
just two cabins we also might have heard
of CVG the precursor to all cannabinoids
or other cannabinoids and then CBN which
is actually not a naturally-occurring
cannabinoid both often used for sleep or
relaxation so but there if you are
actually there over 140 contaminoids at
the last count so just focusing as I
said early on THC and CBD might not be
the right method to offer the right
product to the customer but not only 140
cannabinoids they're already over 200
terpenes identified in the cannabis
plant and terpene is what makes up the
smell and the flavor plant but terpenes
are not just present cannabis they are
present in basically everything that
smells limonene is called limonene
because it was first found in laminates
better kara finally in the home you lean
also known in other plants but a care of
filing is actually would ask this
peppery taste and but then they're so
many more care terpenes of interest and
while it might be interesting or it
might be a good business thought of not
using the terpenes derived from the
cannabis plant but using them from other
sources like lemons the problem there is
that we can identify the first 10 or 50
most dominant terpenes but as there are
over 200 that in their combination make
up the complex player flavor complex
flavor profile of the cannabis plant
trying to recreate it is very very
difficult so it might not be the root
best method to do this but again we're
not yet done
they're also flavonoids that add to the
complexity of the plant and while
flavonoids are right now not tested for
in the cannabis industry they do hold
very interesting biological effects and
should be considered when planning your
raw process your drying process and your
extraction method but we're still not
done we have further compounds that of
biological activity and interest alcohol
actions aldehydes and it quickly becomes
very complex so we have so many
molecules of interest maybe we have a
method to present those to the patient
and customer so extract might be a great
way because just having flower limits
you are consumption method and might go
against the idea of a healthy patient
when we then smokes a joint so extract
might be the way forward so extra X come
in all shapes and forms and they come
from different processing methods
different application methods
consumption methods or just interests of
the patient so what are those act rights
used for we use some strainer as a
concentrate to inhale through heating's
or dabbing or other forms of smoking but
they can also be used as a base to make
further products like a sublingual
tincture evade cartridge a cream so many
possibilities and they have to be
considered depending on what the patient
needs what illness is he other the
patient have or outcomes the client
targets so when I think about making
extracts I have to consider many
different factors and it was actually
one of my first bosses when I entered
the cannabis industry taught me to make
the best abstract and I run into the
problem that I don't really know what a
best extract is because of all the
problems I just mentioned we have too
many things to consider so what might be
the best for one patient or method
application method might not be the best
for another patient so but there are
still a few underlying principles that
we all have to consider and so if we
think what is the best method is maybe
the method that produces the most but if
I just think about weight as my
benchmark for success then if I juice
some families I get 60 percent yield
it's all water but it's the high number
on the yield side so that might not be
the best benchmark so if I consider a
production cost a PVC pipe a lighter and
a cheesecloth should be really cheap and
my production costs a low but I think
open blasting like this in your backyard
or blowing up your shed might not be the
best method after all so I think we
should consider the extraction quality
that we represent the cannabis plant in
our extracts we don't want to make a
nice alert we don't want to extract
things that the patient is not in need
of but we also want to give a carbon
copy of the plant if possible so a large
last aspect to consider is the legal
part different municipalities different
cities have different rules and
different states or two
we all know what Jeff Sessions stand on
cannabis is but what does your local
government think of it so we are an
outcall are based in the County of San
Diego and while the city of San Diego
was one of the first California cities
to allow the manufacturing and sale of
recreational cannabis the County of San
Diego decided to forbid this so with
further restrictions while we are
licensed for medical marijuana
we are only licensed to produce with co2
we are not allowed to use ethanol
extraction or beauty so therefore in my
case I stick with co2 extraction and
that's where I can present the data on
so how do i optimize I have to consider
a few factors what I am actually looking
for and I could look for yield per run
but again yield might not be the best
method and firaon is a bad process so if
I have limited amount of material that
might be the right way I want to get out
as much as possible but if I have
unlimited material or I have more than I
might be able to process I want to
consider how much how can I produce the
most per week so that's a time factor
here and I'm looking for maybe high
turnover and it is slightly different to
yield per run I can also consider
cannabinoid concentrations so how do I
make a very nice pure extract or
high-end cannabinoids so that I don't
have to make too many post-processing
steps also I can think about the Turcan
concentration or the content because
Tara penis what gives flavors what might
be also a large influence on the enter
our chef act so if I have a very
flavorful noter can concentrate it might
not be what the customer needs
and then my favorite number is actually
recovery that considers of how much THC
for example was in the plant to begin
with and how much do I recovered at the
end because if I make a 60% extract but
all of it is water or fats and
chlorophyll that doesn't help me but if
my plant that I put into the extractor
has a 15% can average content and if we
have a 10 pound 10-pound extractor
loading we therefore should get one and
a half pound of extract out of pure THC
out so if I now only hit a pound of THC
then I know I wasn't very good in my
recovery and I know that I can't get
more than one and a half pounds so I
cannot mathematically go over 15% yield
if we align THC recovery and yields here
so recovery is a very good number to
check your process okay so how can I
influence my extraction I can in this
co2 case I can change the temperature I
can change pressure I also can consider
run time a flow rate of the pump is a
very important often overlooked factor
but also particle size anecdotally we
know that candied sugar does not
dissolve as fast in your coffee yes
powdered sugar would be and so the same
should hold true for cannabis when
extracting so as an example let's look
at recovery in time how old as time
conference my recovery if I look at it
the longer I run the machine the better
my recovery is but when I look at the
graph a bit closer there is actually a
slight change in behavior initially we
have a straight line so basically the
longer I run the more I get out and just
run along
and I do better and that is when the
extraction is in its mass transfer fades
it just it can't go faster but it also
doesn't slow down all the time but
eventually it will we see a diffusion
phase later on in the extraction process
and at that point we are entering
diminishing returns so when I run longer
I don't get out more or as much as I
would expect so if I would be on a
recovery per run base I would run longer
because I want to get artis more edge
master possible but if I want to heal or
I can recovery per week I should have
stopped now because I'm going to
diminish my returns and also this
diffusion based is on a chemical side
not only lower yield but also the
extract Constitution changes when in the
mass transfer my extract at point and at
the five hour mark might be the same as
the extra coming out at the 15 hour mark
when I enter the fusion phase we see a
change in composition so there is less
THC to extract so it slowly still
trickles out but the co2 starts to pick
up other things so chlorophylls
fast are now coming out so I'm really
putting myself in a bind if I we're
trying to push further and this point of
switch over from mass transfer to
diffusion is about 80% recovery so I'm
already hinting you should really
understand a lot of what is in your
plant and what is your extract target so
lots of testing really helps here your
local analytical app will be very
thankful but depending on your operation
size you might also consider
using your own equipment so with the
right staff in your company if we'll pay
all the llama okay so this was our time
example but we can also look at particle
size for our recovery and as I already
mentioned and I don't we think there
should be an effect but actually looks
at a let's look at the data so when we
use the same starting material the same
amount of extract the loading the same
conditions on temperature pressure and
time so therefore they're not important
in this example and the only thing we
change is particle size we see that we
get higher recoveries with smaller
particle size and it's a it's an obvious
trend here there might be the fear that
when the particle becomes too small my
extraction policy might go down because
now chlorophyll can leach out quicker
but under operation condition we have
not seen that drop academically yes that
is true it can happen but then you're
talking about very small sample matter
preparation volumes in an experimental
setting but if we're thinking of
high-throughput large volume extraction
operations our case we have a ten-pound
loading her run we we won't be able to
grind that fine with a machine that
would produce the grind in a timely
fashion we don't want to spend five days
making a very fine powder to then
x-factor for a day we need to be able to
do this in an hour or two and so those
machines don't grind us fine and
therefore we don't run into problems so
how does our extra our fine particles
actually look
here on the left side we see some of our
rhyming experiment particle sizes and on
the right yeah that's how hard actually
looks when a council of the mill and
that's my colleague once told me we are
definitely not in Kansas anymore and I
don't think Ken's a in the last cannabis
so it's good the work that we are in San
Diego but as I just showed to you if we
change particle size we extract more so
assumingly faster but if I also did my
study on time then I run into the
problem that I change one factor and
then the other factor is not valid
anymore in my data so I would have to
rerun my time experiment after I run my
particle experiment and then basically
BEC and forth and I try a third factor
and I keep on redoing everything every
time and I think we can do that more
efficient and to do that more efficient
we're leaving something that's called
design of experiment for that we're
looking at multiple factors at the same
time we can test the whole space of
possibilities and we can even see
second-order effects that you will not
see if you only change one factor at a
time and I like fast and efficient and
German so that's what I went for
so how do we execute a design of
experiment and I go directly now to our
execution and results because while I
really enjoy the underlying math and
statistics behind it when I have
discussed that in a conference setting
before I had people leaving I counted
that Lester win for myself but
to get now to the more interesting
actually results I will spare you this
if you have any further questions about
the underlying math please feel free to
ask me afterwards and I will provide you
with all the necessary information but
let's talk about the execution so we are
looking in this example at pressure and
time and here I give you the upper and
lower limits of the temperature and
pressure and please be aware that I show
you the temperatures in Celsius because
as the European I still don't understand
the Fahrenheit idea even if it was
invented by a German but I think that's
just cruelty that we Germans like and
just push that onto you and deal you
have to deal with it I like I like
Celsius and then psi for the pressure
which is actually now an imperial unit
and on a metric anymore but my extractor
was built in the u.s. only gives me psi
and it also gives you an idea here
changing between metrics and imperial
units how messed up the cannabis
industry still is I we are trying to be
better and become a real industry but
we're still stuck in in the past in some
areas and in our own ways and I just
take that as an example here okay so
when I want to look at temperature and
pressure I can think of a space and I
donate that here's our square and I can
just do five experiments donated by the
points on this space to look at the
possible possibilities because the math
but I spared you will then compute a
surface that spans all possible
combinations of temperature and pressure
now on the right side I give you a table
of all the experiments I run we double
the middle point the C experiment tools
to get refugee
ability and the standard error because
if I happy to represent
don't have any option or possibility of
optimizing anything if I can't trust my
own experiment so therefore we had to do
this
DC experiment twice but I can also do
this same method for the subcritical
spatial liquid co2 because I've heard so
often over and over again that
subcritical is better some critical
extraction is so much better and again I
don't really know what the best is but I
know how to look for it so this were
these are the experimental conditions
for our subcritical space and to just
give you a better idea of what I was
testing or where I was testing in the
space I give you the phase diagram here
in the middle and co2 gas phase is the
nature this grey the solid is red and
then the liquid and the supercritical
space just stay in the middle and the
squares with a point in the middle is
basically the experimental conditions we
tested there might be a little bit of a
slip but the we didn't test gas face
your to just it was in that border
region okay so what our results as I
promised you after you did these five
experiments and you used a little bit of
math and a bit of programming you see
these surfaces and surface gives you in
this case the THC recovery in the
supercritical space and I also show you
the formula that actually donates this
surface and when you look at it that the
factor for temperature so XT it has a 15
in front of it about fourteen point nine
but Russia has a factor of 123 so we can
already get an idea that pressure is far
more influential on our recovery than
temperatures but both are positively
aligned with recovery
so therefore more pressure on more
temperature we get more year or more
recovery and we can easily see that on
the surface we can also look sane
recovery surface for this subcritical
condition and here the surface becomes a
little bit more interesting but the
earlier ideas that pressure have the
largest influence on meal and sports are
positively correlated still holds true
it's now at 126 or slightly change
temperatures actually negatively
correlated now with yield or recovery
but the the second-order effect of
pressure temperature together is
positive still and therefore leads to
this very interesting surface shape but
again high pressure high temperature in
the socrata gives us the best field
recoveries so hotel pain concentration
that is something different now first
off I'm not showing just the raw
recovery I'm talking about the the
concentration so wanting a really light
terpene rich and in our case cannabinoid
depleted extract like I show on the Left
what's the goal of this optimization and
the formula we are now getting really
good at this math reading is that and
both temperature and pressure are
negatively correlated to the Turcan
concentration so therefore in the
supercritical space if we have just
above the critical point that might be
the best condition for our turf
extract we can also look at this on the
subcritical space and the surface not
time but if you think back about the
face diagram actually it's pointing a
bar at the same point in space on that
face diagram it's pointing towards the
super the critical point so it seems
that the critical point is what is
critical for good terpenes so with all
this we we've now quickly with a total
of twelve experiments so it's about a
month work in the lab and then a few
long weekends on the computer for the
math programming we finished our
optimization but this is right now it's
all theoretical it's math it's chemistry
is what I like but obviously my boss
it's asking me is it the best extract so
let's look at it because that's how you
normally present it your extract in the
first place and these were some of the
extracts we found and I think they look
somewhat similar to what most of you
might have seen coming out of the co2
extractor
I personally make them nicknamed them
diarrhea but I think we can do better
and one of the very interesting acts
facts that we found is these in the
middle they are actually 80 percent THC
acid straight out of the extractor you
have these dry rocks or powder that are
just really high in THC acid
and this THC acid that's what'll
actually in the plan not THC th C's
decarboxylated after you smoke or when
he smoked it or he did in other forms
THC acid this waters in the plant so if
you want to give the right
representation of the flower the acid
forms what you have to go for but it
won't matter make you high it's not
psychoactive but it doesn't have healing
properties and I use healing properties
here loosely not a medical doctors so
it's not mine to claim those but we're
working with doctors and nurses and the
parents we have formulated THC acid as
the startling world tincture for a to
yield epileptic patient because we
really didn't want to make that child
her children her a child high but we
wanted to offer the potential healing
properties of the cannabis plant and
smoking was not an option either so
having these THC acid Ridge rocks
whether way forward because we had
already found in earlier twice that pure
CBD wasn't working and THC acid isolate
is very expensive and again it it's an
individual molecule and as I showed you
earlier it's the combination of multiple
cannabinoids that make it interesting so
therefore our whole plant THC a rich
extract or rocks was the solution and it
worked the kid has seen a significant
reduction in seizures and the mother
reports very happily on the progress of
the child but for most of us most of our
customers THC rich extracts it's what
what everyone wants we hear so often
clarity comes they cartridges flow
better with the THC
extract not these rocks obviously so how
can we make those and with our optimized
conditions this is how our extract looks
this is how it looks straight out of the
extractor we did not winterize we did
not distill that's how it comes out I
also think winterization is definitely
not the solution anyway what technically
it is a solution but process orientated
I don't see the point why you have to
winterize something and also a smaller
winterization chemically it's a
precipitation but I'm not I'm not a fan
sorry okay going on
now that we did the study of subcritical
and supercritical I can now compare and
contrast because earlier I said people
said south critical is better so is it
what if we look at recovery TFC recovery
in the same time frame because it's
yield or recovery per week that we are
after we see a a 20% point higher
recovery in supercritical condition also
our terpene fraction actually become of
better quality when we use supercritical
we have about 10 percent point higher
concentration of terpenes at a Margy
higher yield and we can also look at
other effects so when we now have the
whole dataset we can start digging into
effects and behaviors on a on a
molecular level and it turns out that
THC is more soluble in co2 than THC acid
and I show you that both in a super in
the subcritical space here our starting
material has the decarboxylation rate of
8 or 14 percent respectively and when we
extract on use short period of time
we raise this decarboxylation rate so
that is the strong indicator that THC
extracted first the THC acid stayed
behind therefore we improved our THC to
THC acid ratio but when we run longer to
completion then we come back to our
starting material ratio showing that we
didn't see any further decarboxylation
in the process and just kept the
starting material ratios and we can use
that to actually affect the THC to THC
acid ratio so if someone would want
harshly decarboxylated material we can
offer that thanks to our data sets also
we can look at CBD to THC behavior
because CBD while it is an isomer of THC
so it has the same amount of molecules
same amount of atoms in the molecule it
does behave different in co2 it actually
extracts faster so it's more soluble and
again I look at our ratios and starting
material after a short time and after a
long time and you see that it the ratio
increases to the favor of CBD and then
eventually comes back to the starting
material ratio so again we can use this
to adjust the ratio so if a patient
would need a a 3 to 1 CVD to THC ratio
but in the flower you either get all th
co CVD or one-to-one genetically there
isn't anything that does three to one
you could either mix different strains
or we could actually take a 1 to 1
strain adjust our extraction conditions
and then get the 3 to 1 ratio so coming
back to the title of the talk we can
control that cannabinoids a terpenes in
the extract thanks to all the math that
I had to slide through earlier and as a
bonus point decarboxylation of THC of
THC acid
actually faster than CVD acid we have
seen that trying to become oxalate the
flower in Arvin trying to decarboxylate
the oil and an oven or other
experimental setups I'm still not sure
why I think it's a very interesting
chemical problem and I guess with some
further kinetic studies or computational
studies this could be figured out but
for the producer that's just something
to consider if you have your standard
methods to decarboxylate THC rich oil
and you now have the CBD rich oil those
methods will work you need longer or
higher temperature so please keep that
in mind you can't just take your SOPs
and take them from one process to the
next there are some stepping stones to
always consider okay so can we enrich
minor cannabinoids and yes we can it's
it's an interesting and cool effect if
minor cannabinoids is what we are going
for CVG in this case or maybe a THC D
that is a minor constituent of the plant
we can enrich here as well so I've now
showed you lots of result examples but
like let's just overall think about this
again off the consider off the title
Wells said controlling turkeys so when
we think about terpenes terpenes how s
the last studies have shown might
actually be the best way of looking at
strains it's not the name but the flavor
that distinguishes the plant so I'm
tokens are the flavor so when we go by a
study on the Netherlands by Professor
hosaka he found that sativas or what is
said to be a sativa are rich in mono
Turkey
and in the curse of rich incest butter
beans so now then for me comes the
question as an extractor and I play with
it and yes we can we can actually change
due to the different solubilities of
monoterpene supposed Sasquatch other
beings we can change the ratio and so
boldly stated I could take a sativa
flower and turn it into an indica oil
and I thought that was a cool effect I
don't think that I can turn a Sour
Diesel into a cookie or tangerine
flavored strain but at least we can
tweak a little and I see this here not
so much on the side of being able to
customize strains but being able to
correct for any small variance in the
grow so if your indoor grow or
greenhouse growing small variations from
from harvest to harvest you can adjust
or dampen it with the extraction okay so
other extraction methods and see I made
the mistake myself it's the separation
methods if we think about Rossum and if
we look at the recovery and that was the
number that really really struck me was
we are getting 72% recovery and I told
you 80% is what we go for on co2 so this
is a really high and efficient problem
by inefficient process and again I like
my mask so we use the same process of
optimization for the rosin and we found
some interesting or annoying results
that yield and quality are negatively
aligned so if you want a lot of yield
you get a little quality out if you want
good quality you don't get much yield so
that might be a reason why it is such a
connoisseur product but again we were
able to play with temperature and
pressure on the rosin or temperature
time on our rosin press to optimize this
we also looked at ice water harsh
and while it looks very nice under the
high potency at a concentrate
we only got a 25 or so cover II so we
have to now think what do you do with
the material after the ice water hash
separation can you can you use in a
second process or can you optimize we
have we've tried a little we haven't
found much to optimize so we have to
think of the secondary process but again
think about this for your own flow for
your own operation test your process
throughout look at what's your starting
material what's happening through the
extraction what happened what is at the
end have you extracted everything or not
yes lots of analytics I'm an organic
chemist by training I didn't think it
was that cool analytics but it really
helps your operations yeah with that I'm
actually coming to a close and I have to
thank the supporting companies in this
because apex was very nice to help us
with optimising our extractor I call it
now Frank an extractor because we had to
make quite a few changes to the
extractor setup
thanks to or not thanks to the
optimization process and the math I
found that the extremes were the best
conditions so we had to be able to run
the machine as the tech strains what it
was designed for so we had to add a few
things to the machine to get that all
running and also pop consistent particle
size is what really makes your extract
good consistent our particle size will
give you a consistent fine separated
extract with the high throughput and to
do that a kitchen grinder a kitchen mill
just doesn't cut it you need a
professional mill and fridge were so
kind to help us with a lot of expertise
on their machine and I even visited
their production site in Germany
they can't play with cannabis there but
they grind a lot of hops and that gets
you a lot of beer and German beer so it
was a good trip let's say it was
illiterate
but it's not only their manufacturers
that helped us with it most important to
the whole process is a great team and
for that you need your colleagues with
expertise to help you in all ways and
here on the right you see Blake cause he
is my extraction manager he was most
instrumental in all the data I presented
to you today but met celiac my
production manager or Taylor tried
formulation they play on all the other
aspects of controlling cannabinoids and
turkeys in the flour and the extract or
ultimately the product and then on the
Left I talked about analytics and
someone has to handle analytics and
someone has to be the annoying person
telling you that this is not to standard
so you can't give it to your customer
and for that you need a strong Quality
Assurance person and Chris Katina has
been instrumental in this process so
with that I'm just at my last slide
already I thank you very much for
listening in I'm happy to answer all
your questions but I properly wasn't
able to answer in the short time frame
and I wish you a nice day thank you dr.
Rogan for that informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar so if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button I'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started
our first question is why is
winterization not a good method
so as a chemist I'm puzzled by the
question or by the process of
winterization so you extract something
from the plant so you'd say you target
egg to extract something so you have now
your extract and then you have to remove
something from the extract
why didn't you extract wrong in the
first place so that's why winterization
really presents also it's not
motorisation is a precipitation and then
the third aspect you use this very
expensive co2 machine to not introduce
any other liquid solvent into your
extract but then you're using ethanol as
the post-processing material for suppose
the same step and then you have ethanol
on your product so not a fan what are
the limitations of your method and set
up so I'm there there we go okay so I'm
back on I was muted for a second sorry
so the limitations are but I'm we're
doing good line analytics so we're using
an outside testing laboratory to do the
analytics so the limitation there is
that I have to bring that over wait for
the results so there's a little bit of a
lag so that limits my optimization then
I'm using a 2000 psi future extractor
with a 1 separator setup there are
machines that can do for higher
pressures which would probably optimize
our recovery and yield per week setup
also with multiple separators you can
further separate your extract after the
extraction in the recovery part and then
finally we are limited to co2 for law
reasons but every solvent has a
different behavior on the cannabinoid
solubility so with other solvents I
should be able to
different representations of the plant
so I always tried to stay true to the
plant but tweaking the ends is dependent
on the solvent he views well thank you
very much I would like to once again
thank dr. Rogan for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June 29 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye